wie schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute
live heute mit diesem thema mehr druck
auf ungeimpfte wie weit darf das gehen
wir sprechen über die zukünftigen corona
pläne der zukünftigen ampel regierung
mit unserem hauptstadtstudio
korrespondenten theo koll wir sprechen
außerdem mit dem rechtswissenschaftler
steffen augsburg an der uni jena erst
gleichzeitig auch mitglied des deutschen
ethikrates und wir sprechen mit unserem
korrespondenten in wien in österreich
mit wolf christian ulrich der für uns
heute am ersten tag wo der sogenannte
lock down für ungeimpfte gilt uns ein
erstes fazit gibt wenn ihr fragen oder
kommentare habt dann schreibt die hier
zeit live in den stream da wo er gerade
unterwegs seid oder schickt uns eure
fragen kommentare an die e-mailadresse
die er jetzt eingeblendet seht und wir
wollen beginnen zunächst mal mit den
neuen plänen dieser dann doch wohl
zukünftigen ampel regierung die wir
haben werden aus spd grünen und fdp die
haben also einen neuen gesetzesentwurf
vorgestellt um gegen die steigenden
corona zahlen in deutschland anzukommen
und denen dann auch gleich wieder
nachgeschärft in anbetracht der
aktuellen lage und was worum es da genau
geht und was sich dadurch vielleicht
verändern könnte das hat christiane
hübscher zunächst mal für uns
zusammengefasst
die ampelkoalition ist noch gar nicht im
amt da muss sie ihre pandemie politik
bereits hektisch nachschärfen 3g soll
künftig für den gesamten öffentlichen
personennah und fernverkehr gelten auch
für schülerbeförderung und taxen das
heißt ungeimpfte müssen sich künftig
testen lassen bevor sie bus und bahn
nutzen
verkehrsverbände kritisieren das als
kaum praktikabel fahrscheine impf
genesenen und test nachweise
gleichzeitig zu kontrollieren das ginge
maximal stichprobenhaft die länder
sollen je nach infektions lage
entscheiden können ob sie auch wieder
kontakt beschränkungen im öffentlichen
und privaten raum anordnen auch die
kapazität von veranstaltungen dürfen die
länder beschränken nur den lockdown für
alle den soll es nicht mehr geben
ausgangssperren werden wir nicht
tolerieren nicht weiter zulassen wir
werden auch die schließung von
einzelhandelsgeschäften oder schulen
flächendeckend so in der form nicht also
ausschließen in der länder
öffnungsklausel das ganze vorerst
befristet bis zum 19 märz nächsten
jahres 3g 2g oder zweig plus der
gesetzentwurf der künftigen
ampelkoalition soll alles möglich mache
ich hoffe sehr dass die
ministerpräsidenten und minister
präsidentinnen sich darauf am donnerstag
bei der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
einigen können die möglichkeit haben sie
nach unseren gesetzen und am donnerstag
auch soll der bundestag das geänderte
infektionsschutzgesetz beschließen
was da gerade in berlin los ist das
ordnen theo koll unser hauptstadtstudio
korrespondent jetzt für uns einen guten
abend theo koll
jetzt ist ja gerade die neue regierungen
die steht noch gar nicht so richtig hat
er schon etwas vorgelegt es gibt ja aber
tatsächlich auch noch eine
geschäftsführende regierung hat die mit
diesen vorschlägen da jetzt auch noch
was zu tun oder wer ist da jetzt
eigentlich genau gerade am zug also das
ist eine hervorragende frage weil im
grunde sind beide am zug und keiner so
richtig also es gilt ja immer noch die
bestehende gesetzeslage nämlich die
änderung des infektionsschutzgesetzes
mit dem fast bis ende november im die
geschäftsführende regierung sehr vieles
machen könnte aber muss man wirklich in
aller deutlichkeit sagen in den
vergangenen wochen nicht getan hat die
ampel parteien also die künftige
regierung wenn es denn dazu kommt haben
als allererste maßnahme gesagt wir
wollen diese epidemische notlagen
gesetzgebung abschaffen wir wollen sie
ersetzen durch einen eigenen
maßnahmenkatalog und haben im grunde ein
nur sehr kleines eher harmloses paket an
maßnahmen vorgelegt also abstandsregeln
jene usw also das waren
sehr schwache maßnahmen die man
vorgeschlagen hat und das lief im grunde
völlig gegen die entwicklung der
pandemie und wir haben jetzt die
schlimmste situation in der pandemie und
gleichzeitig hat die ampel ganz
schwacher maßnahmen vorgelegt also dass
die überhaupt nicht zusammen und
deswegen haben sie übers wochenende
jetzt hektisch verhandelt und haben
gesagt wir müssen nach schaffen wir
müssen nachlegen wir haben gerade in
beitrag gehört und haben jetzt jede
menge weitere maßnahmen in planung die
sollen am donnerstag in der zweiten und
dritten lesung dann durch den bundestag
und dann am freitag durch den bundesrat
und wären dann idealerweise dann nächste
woche
anfang nächster woche dann auch gesetz
anfang nächster woche ist natürlich in
so einer pandemie dann doch irgendwo
wieder eine lange zeit gibts da auch
kritische stimmen in berlin jetzt
entweder an die an die geschäftsführende
regierung oder dann an die neuen dass da
jetzt gerade noch nichts passiert weil
jeder tag ist für die kliniken die da
gerade ja auch teilweise voll laufen ja
ein verlorener tag also gibt's kritik
auch daran an dieser untätigkeit es gibt
eigentlich keine positiven stimmen die
die derzeitige corona politik überhaupt
betreffen es gibt nur kritik und das
finde ich auch zu recht denn wir sind
wirklich in einer dramatischen situation
und in einer historischen situation
zwischen diesen beiden regierungen wo im
grunde in aller deutlichkeit gezeigt
wird dass die einen zu wenig machen
diesen die auslaufenden regierungs zum
teil auf jobsuche zum teil die kanzlerin
fährt durch die welt und verabschiedet
sich es gab keine flammende tv ansprache
der kanzlerin kein aufruf zum impfen es
gab mal eine impf aktionswoche aber das
hätte man viel stärker intensivieren
können kreativer vorgehen wie man
menschen zum impfen bringt also da ist
vieles versäumt worden das wird auch
sehr kritisch bemerkt und die neue
regierung wenn sie denn eine wird hat im
grunde den fehler gemacht in ihrer
allerersten maßnahme einen viel zu
schwachen katalog an maßnahmen
vorzulegen es geht zum teil auf das
konto der fdp den die fdp hat während
der ganzen pandemie im prinzip eine
libertäre position vertreten das heißt
sie haben immer gesagt wir wollen keine
grundrechtseingriffe das geht viel zu
weit in die freiheit des einzelnen das
wurde auch von vielen wählern sehr
positiv also gerade der hohe anteil an
jungen wählern bei dem wahlausgang hat
der fdp ja geholfen und hatte auch was
mit dieser position zu tun und das fällt
ihnen im grunde jetzt auf die füße weil
das in der jetzigen pandemie lage nicht
mehr angemessen ist und jetzt wenn wir
konkrete ein bisschen auch auf die
maßnahmen schauen die da die wir
teilweise schon wissen die also bekannt
sind heute geisterte dann so eine andere
information noch durch die medien
zunächst mal ist hieß also eine
impfpflicht für bestimmte berufsgruppen
die sonne kommen das hörte man aus der
richtung von katrin göring eckardt von
den grünen die kurz darauf hin aber
wieder zurückgerudert zu sein scheint
mit dieser information was wissen sie
darüber was es da dran
also meine lesart der entwicklung ist
das offensichtlich ist da entweder ein
missverständnis gegeben hat dass die
grünen davon ausgegangen sein dass es
vereinbart ist und
dass dann bekannt gegeben haben und
offensichtlich bei den liberalen das
dann eine wendung zu viel war ein
zugeständnis ein kompromiss zu viel oder
aber es war ein
versuch der grünen im grunde
vollendete tatsachen zu schaffen ohne
dass es wirklich schon vereinbart waren
und die fdp dann gesagt haben also leute
so geht es nicht dass müsst ihr bitte
zurück nehmen also eine von beiden
optionen wird es gewesen sein
ich tendiere zur ersten weil die fdp
natürlich also wirklich schon sehr sehr
viele zugeständnisse gemacht hat die
eigentlich von ihrer haltung abweichen
wir sehen ja jetzt über das wochenende
sind ja ganz viele sachen möglich
geworden zweig zweig plus
kontakt beschränkungen im notfall das
sind ja alle sachen die die fdp
eigentlich in der form nicht will und
noch zum schluss müssen wir natürlich
auch ein bisschen darüber sprechen also
sie haben es auch gerade angesprochen es
wird über diverse diskutiert 3g 2g
zweige plus es geht auf jeden fall schon
auch immer darum natürlich um die
debatte geimpft oder nicht geimpft wer
darf was jetzt haben unsere nachbarn in
österreich also heute den lockdown für
ungeimpfte in bayern gilt ab morgen eine
22 g regelung für viele bereiche des
öffentlichen lebens könnte so was
ähnliches bei uns also auch bundesweit
dann kommen also das dann wirklich für
nur noch für geimpfte gewisse dinge
einfach möglich sind und für ungeimpfte
das nicht also da gibt es zwei hürden
die eine ist eine rechtliche nach meinem
verständnis ich bin kein jurist gibt es
ja auch unterschiedliche sichtweisen ob
es möglich ist dass man das für
bestimmte gruppen also für ungeimpfte
festlegt aber das wesentliche glaube ich
ist ein politisches problem weil die fdp
sich bisher sehr strikt gegen weitere
lockdown svh endet also man hat jetzt
zugestanden dass es kontakt
beschränkungen geben soll und das ist ja
im prinzip eine mildere form
des lok downs also dass man damit im
grunde erreicht dass es weniger kontakte
gibt eine ausgangssperre ist ja im
prinzip dann dasselbe nur in radikaler
also ich wäre überrascht wenn die fdp
das mittragen würde
vielen dank für diese einschätzung heute
abend an theo koll zdf hauptstadtstudio
vielen dank
und über die eben angesprochenen
juristischen fragen und auch die
ethischen fragen können wir jetzt
wunderbar sprechen mit dem
rechtswissenschaftler und mitglied des
deutschen ethikrats steffen augsburg
schönen guten abend herr ochs berg
gerade habe ich sie noch nicht so gut
auf meinem ohr gehört aber das war ja
auch nur eine kurze antwort wir testen
das gleich mal weil ich habe direkt
natürlich die erste frage an sie also
wenn sie das jetzt alles zu hören was da
vielleicht also in planung ist mit zwei
g2 g + regeln 3g ist das denn juristisch
und ethisch wenn man beides mal
betrachtet in ordnung und korrekt
ungeimpfte anders zu behandeln als
geimpfte menschen
juristen würden ganz klassisch sagen das
haben das heißt wir müssen schauen das
ist natürlich im prinzip richtig ist
unterschiedliche risikoprofile zu
berücksichtigen und damit auch menschen
die diese risikoprofile aufweisen
unterschiedlich zu behandeln
das ist nicht nur etwas was zulässig ist
sondern ging es zum wissen rat ist das
sogar geboten dass es ein punkte in der
ganzen immunität ausweis im voraus weiß
debatte ja schon reichlich hin und her
gewendet wo was wir aber auch sehen ist
es natürlich grenzen dessen gibt beweist
man diese ungleichbehandlung treiben
kann und wir müssen berücksichtigen dass
unter den bedingungen der delta variante
die annahme dass die geimpften die
genesenen
signifikant weniger ansteckend sind eben
nicht mehr in dieser deutlichkeit gilt
es gibt eine gesunkene infektiosität
aber die sind jedenfalls teilen immer
noch ansteckend und können damit auch
andere entsprechend gefährden das ist
ein problem was dann den umgang mit
ungeimpften insbesondere an geht aber es
gibt auch im durchbrüche das heißt
unsere vorstellung die wir mal hatten
dass die impfung gewissermaßen das
allein seligmachende mittel ist die hat
doch allein durch die faktischen
entwicklung der letzten wochen und
monate erhebliche dämpfer erlitten und
wir müssen darauf jetzt auch die
normative reaktion anpassen das ist das
was glaube ich im moment zu erkennen ist
wie schwierig das ist sich einerseits
natürlich nicht abzuwenden von den
impfungen die ein wirksames nach allem
was wir wissen sicheres mittel sind aber
eben nicht so wirksam wie wir uns das
gewünscht haben und deshalb eben ergänzt
werden müssen um andere mittel und das
ist im grunde genommen das was wir
zurzeit sehen und dann kommt ihr zu was
er kann ja völlig zu recht gesagt hat
dass er einer unglücklichen
übergangssituation sind politisch wo die
eine seite offensichtlich nicht mehr
lust hat und die andere seite sich
politisch profilieren möchte mit einer
optimistischen strategie in ihre neue
regierungszeit starten möchte das
ergebnis ist dass wir eine sehr
erfahrene unglückliche letztlich unklare
regelung situation haben und jetzt so
langsam man den eindruck hat die
beteiligten immerhin beginnen diese
scherben bisschen aufzuheben
dazu gibt es viele kommentare und fragen
im stream da möchte ich jetzt auch gerne
mal reingucken zunächst mal wird hier
das immer wieder thema natürlich wie
auch
ob jemand natürlich blieb ich habe mich
gerade den fragen verloren aber jetzt
suche ich hier raus also hier die erste
frage kommt von till dorfschmied bei
youtube und zwar möchte er gerne wissen
2g 3g und locker und nur für ungeimpfte
menschen ist doch offensichtlich ganz
klar verfassungswidrig wie kann das nur
unsere lösung sein fragt er sich
mehr ganz klar verfassungswidrig hängt
natürlich sehr stark davon ab worauf man
das bezieht also ich kann mir
tatsächlich auch überhaupt nicht
vorstellen dass man eine ausgangssperre
für umgehen da hat wie sie etwa in
österreich weitgehend gilt das schadet
mir deutlich über das ziel
hinauszuschießen nicht mehr
verhältnismäßig zu sein weil damit ja
irgendwie die grund vermutung besteht
dass jeder schritt vor die haustür wir
haben wir auch schon so gefährlich aber
es gibt natürlich andere szenarien
andere zusammenkünfte weil dann mann den
man sehr wohl sagen kann dass das
zusammensein von geimpften aber immer
noch potenzielle infektionen also
ansteckenden menschen und ungeimpften
problematisch ist also denken sie an
größere veranstaltung mit tausenden von
teilnehmern sinken sie an diese szenen
im kölner karneval oder
an situation wo man einfach sagen kann
da entstehen besondere risiken und das
zu begrenzen ist durchaus vorstellbar
dass dort auch eine verfassungsrechtlich
zulässig wenn dem eine entsprechende
gefährdungssituation entgegensteht und
das ist im grunde genommen das
aktionsjahr die verfassung verpflichtet
an dieser stelle genau hinzusehen welche
risiken bestehen und mit welchen
maßnahmen kann man diesen risiken so
wirksam begegnen dass gleichzeitig
möglichst wenig freiheitsrechte
beeinträchtigt werden bevor wir viele
weitere von diesem spannenden fragen mit
ihnen besprechen wollen wir mal live
nach österreich nach wien schalten zu
meinem kollegen dem korrespondent vor
ort war christian ullrich denn immer
wieder war heute auch schon jetzt bei
uns angesprochen und thema der lockdown
für ungeimpfte der seit heute in
österreich gilt wolf christian sie
stehen da jetzt gerade vor dem
weihnachtsmarkt glaube ich im
hintergrund zu erkennen zunächst mal
vielleicht die frage wie ist denn das
jetzt gerade im öffentlichen leben es
bisschen ruhiger auf den straßen seit
heute kann man das sagen sind viel mehr
menschen jetzt also zu hause oder wie es
die lage
also als ich heute morgen ins büro
gefahren bin da war die bahn voll jetzt
ist montagabend der markt hinter mir ist
ein anderer weihnachtsmarkt hat geöffnet
sind trotzdem viele leute unterwegs wie
anbieter gesehen von einkaufszentren wo
viele leute unterwegs sind also wir
können hier in wien nicht wirklich sagen
dass jetzt weniger los ist mag
vielleicht auch daran liegen dass er
doch in wien mehr menschen geimpft sind
als in anderen teilen österreichs in
oberösterreich beispielsweise sind die
impfzahlen ja doch geringer insofern
würde ich sagen es zeigt sich jetzt noch
nicht so ganz wir hatten auch wir können
das thema kontrolle gleich auch nochmal
ansprechen erlebnis wohl leute ins kino
oder im fernsehen geschildert haben dass
sie dann im einkaufszentrum waren dass
sie dort keine kontrollen gesehen haben
eine frau sagte ich war beim c&a und
dann sagte die reporterin ja aber da
dürfen sie doch gar nicht rein
sagt sie ja das stimmt ich habe mich gar
kein impfpass aber ich war eben drin und
das zeigt ein bisschen wie die situation
doch jetzt an diesem tag 1 lockdown für
ungeimpfte in wien war aber und das ist
glaube ich ein ganz wichtiger punkt
dennoch zeigt es wirkung es sind heute
sehr viele leute vor den impfzentren
angestanden viel mehr als sonst und man
muss auch dazu sagen dass wir ja seit
einer woche jetzt zweig im öffentlichen
leben haben das heißt der druck sich
impfen zu lassen um am normalen leben
teilzunehmen abends mit bar zu gehen
abends in die kneipe zu gehen soll ich
dort mit freunden zu treffen dass wird
größer und das wirkt man wir hatten in
der vergangenen woche rund ich glaube
430.000 impfungen der großteil sind
booster impfungen aber jeder dritte
kommt in der tat um seine erste impfung
abzuholen sind viele dabei die sagen
mich nervt das jetzt mit den tests und
mit diesen maßnahmen andere die sagen
ich war immer dagegen ich wollte mich
nicht impfen lassen dabei jetzt beuge
ich mich dem druck und andere wiederum
die sagen ich habe ihn ganz gut damit
gefahren bisher aber jetzt sieht es doch
ein und in dieser situation sollten wir
uns impfen lassen so das bild an diesem
tag 1 und das heißt ja nur noch mit
triftigen grund dürfe man als
ungeimpfter mensch das haus verlassen
was ist denn so ein triftiger grund in
österreich
der weg zur arbeit ist ein triftiger
grund auf der arbeitsstelle geht ja
immer noch 3g das heißt man kann auch
ungeimpfte aber getestet hingehen dann
ist einen grund wenn man ins krankenhaus
gehen möchte oder um jemanden zu pflegen
und natürlich um einkaufen zu gehen man
kann im grunde sagen ungeimpfte dürfen
nicht im moment aus dem haus um einer
freizeitbeschäftigung nachzugehen also
um abends und zum sport zu gehen um in
die bar zu gehen um spaß zu haben das
geht nicht alles was zum und also in die
apotheke gehen das geht natürlich als
alles was zum unmittelbaren zum zum
notwendigen
führendes lebens beiträgt das kann man
machen der spaß ist gestrichen
und jetzt ist es aber auch so ein
bisschen wird das einfach so hingenommen
und da gibt es da schon die ersten
proteste und klagen ich meinen gestern
gelesen zu haben sind ja schon einige
menschen dagegen auf die straße gegangen
oder
ja es ist vor allen dingen zwei wochen
wenn ich richtig war es eine große
demonstration hier in wien
angekündigt wir konnten es heute so
nicht sehen wenn keine proteste hier
gesehen und wahrgenommen
das muss ich jetzt ein stück weit auch
etablieren es ist auch das war ganz
interessant eben auch in der sendung
bisher zu hören von rechtsexperten und
auch von theo koll kurz da wurde auch
die impfpflicht angesprochen es ist im
ganzen wochenende gerungen worden ob
diese
maßnahmen die heute in kraft getreten
ist eine rechtliche grundlage hat und
welche die haben kann und man hat sich
dazu entschlossen diese diese maßnahme
durchzusetzen weil man glaubt das ist
eine rechtliche grundlage dafür gibt und
es war jetzt auch eine der sollte
vielleicht noch mal eine interessante
ergänzung auch zum
experten eben es war jetzt in einer
talkshow eine ehemalige richterin am
verfassungsgericht hof die gesagt hat ja
die freiheit des einzelnen ist richtig
und wichtig aber es gibt ein rechtsgut
das steht klar darüber und das ist dass
die gesellschaft gesund bleiben kann und
wenn dieses ziel erreicht werden muss
dann ist es auch vorstellbar dass andere
dafür empfindliche einschränkungen
hinnehmen müssen und mit diesem argument
hat sie auch gesagt ist eine impfpflicht
in österreich absolut machbar und sie
verstünden nicht warum es nicht gemacht
wird der bundesgesundheitsminister hat
es jetzt vorgeschlagen für die
pflegeberufe
ich würde sagen da kommt noch einiges
nach aber ja die frage nach der
rechtmäßigkeit ist gestellt worden wird
aber im moment so beantwortet und von
den meisten auch so gesehen ja es ist
richtig die gesellschaft muss sich
schützen muss auch die ungeimpften
schützen und dann ist das eine eine
maßnahme die man tragen kann kann zu
diesen fragen nach freiheit recht und
gesetz kommen wir gleich noch mal mit
herrn augsburg zunächst noch mal eine
frage die hier direkt aus dem stream
auch an dich wolf christian
frs lh youtube möchte wissen wie kann
man den lockdown für ungeimpfte
konsequent kontrollieren denn der
bundeskanzler in schellenberg in
österreich sprach er davon dass streng
kontrolliert wird ist es denn der fall
also im fernsehen haben wir heute
gesehen dass eine polizeistreife los
gezogen ist und in vesser kontrolliert
hat meine erfahrung in österreich ist
das immer wenn es solche regeln kommen
dann wird so etwas im fernsehen gezeigt
wenn man zwei tage später hinschaut dann
ist es so weit nicht mehr so ich würde
folgende antwort geben erstens es gibt
diese regel und an diese regel hat man
sich zu halten es gibt auch die regel
dass man 30 fährt in der 30er zonen ist
oder auch nicht in jede 30 oder
kontrolliert aber es gibt hier und da
stichproben und die werden sicherlich
auch hier gemacht aber nicht im großen
stil dazu gibt gar kein personal dann
vorhin ich habe das kurz erzählt diese
szene dieser frau die ungeimpft ins
einkaufszentrum gegangen ist weil die
einkaufscenter dieses spitz treffende
kein dort hatte ich würde sagen es
bestimmt nicht das einzige
einkaufszentrum in österreich das nicht
kontrolliert es gibt sicherlich auch
viele kneipen die nicht kontrollieren
andere das ist meine persönliche
erfahrung in wien noch in den letzten
monaten kontrollieren sehr genau schauen
sehr genau hin fragen du musst den
ausweis dabei haben du musst den
impfpass zeigen da wird doch genau drauf
geguckt wann ist die zweite impfung her
und wenn du den ich hast dann kommst du
nicht rein ich war in einem konzert auch
david zweig auch da muss nachweisen
unglücklicher konzertbesucher hatte also
nun seinen vergessen der kamen nicht
rein ich würde sagen zum großen teil
wird das schon gemacht wenn ihr mich
jetzt fragt wie sieht es aus wenn es
wirklich einen solchen worker und für
ungeimpfte im alter kontrollieren
sicherlich nicht aber in einigen punkten
werden müssen sich leute durchaus auf
stichproben ein lasso oder oder gefasst
machen müssen ja was wenn man sich nicht
daran hält
dann drohen strafen 500 euro kostet das
wäre dann noch meint mit der polizei
diskutieren zu müssen oder renitent wird
und ich kann nur sagen da ist die
österreichische polizei grundsätzlich
etwas griffiger unterwegs als die
deutsche dann bis zu 1500 euro strafe
man sollte sich das also durchaus
überlegen und dann vielleicht noch zum
schluss die frage wurde auch schon
darüber gesprochen was passiert wenn
jetzt die zahlen nicht runtergehen gibt
es auch noch eine stufe drüber wird das
schon diskutiert oder es ist jetzt erst
mal österreich mit diesem blog dann für
ungeimpfte genug beschäftigt
na ja also wir sind glaube ich noch
überhaupt nicht fertig in dieser
situation die inzidenz zahlen steigen
wir sind jetzt bei knapp 900 die lage
auf den intensivstationen ist alles
andere als gelöst experten befürchten
dass sie noch weiter steigen das hieße
dass österreich auf eine systemkritische
lage in den krankenhäusern zusteuert und
deshalb sagt der gesundheitsminister
jetzt auch gerade es ist ja schön dass
jetzt viel mehr leute impfen gehen wegen
dieser wegen dieser neuen regelungen die
es gibt aber den effekt wird natürlich
erst viel später eintreffen deshalb
müssen wir jetzt etwas machen und
schlägt deshalb vor am mittwoch einen
steckt deshalb vor am mittwoch
die nacht gastronomie für alle also auch
für geimpfte zu schließen da wie der
rest der koalition vor allem die
konservativen partout nicht mitgehen der
gesundheitsminister hat auch
vorgeschlagen
eine impfpflicht in gesundheitsberufen
da wird noch darüber diskutiert und das
ist etwas erinnert sich auch übrigens an
das was theo theo koll eben beschrieben
hat große uneinigkeit innerhalb der
regierung man hat lange nicht gehandelt
diese welle ist eine welle mit ansage
jeder hat sie kommen sehen keiner hat
was getan es hat ewig gedauert bis es
gerührt haben jetzt stehen sie hier
jetzt müssen sie irgendwelche regelungen
finden alle sprechen mit
unterschiedlicher sprache wir haben kurz
vorm wochenende jetzt auch am wochenende
aus der regierung unterschiedlichsten
konzepte gehört bis heute widerspricht
kanzler scheinberg öffentlich seinem
gesundheitsminister in wichtigsten
fragen also experten sprechen von einem
kommunikationsdesaster so muss man es
auch wirklich bezeichnen und natürlich
die grünen scheinen mehr voran zu
pressen wollen baslern die schneller und
für alle auch greifen die svp wehrt sich
krass dagegen die wollen unbedingt keine
maßnahmen für die impften argument ist
die leute haben sich impfen lassen das
risiko eingegangen darum sollten sie
jetzt beschränken ihre freiheit jetzt
nehmen das natürlich eine position die
kann man auch vertreten der
gesundheitsminister sieht natürlich was
in den krankenhäusern los ist ich würde
sagen es wird neue maßnahmen geben da
kommt man nicht drumrum es wird sie auch
schneller geben als manchem lieb ist und
ich kann mir auch vorstellen dass auch
geimpfte wieder zurückstecken müssen um
dieser vierten welle zu begegnen
vielen dank wolfs christian ulrich live
nach wien für diese eindrücke und
einschätzung
gerne und jetzt haben wir noch viel zeit
um gemeinsam mit rechtswissenschaftler
steffen augsburg auf eure fragen
einzugehen und ich schau mal rein da hat
sich bestimmt einiges angesammelt schön
sie wiederzusehen herzberg ich schaue
man hier auf unsere kommentare und
fragen als kommentar dass nur kurz am
rande kommt auch öfter dass ich mich
erkältet anhöre es stimmt tatsächlich
war war erkältet und bei mir schlägt das
immer gleich auf die stimme und schon
seit ich ein kleines kind bin und es
geht auch dann nicht mehr so gut weg
also das hängt mir noch nachgetestet auf
corona wurde ich und da ist gott sei
dank nicht rausgekommen aber natürlich
man achtet jetzt auch sowas auch auf
kleinigkeiten alle wir wollen alle
gesund bleiben
also wer sich da gesorgt hat mir geht es
ganz gut danke der nachfrage gut jetzt
zu den wirklich wichtigen dingen den
juristischen und ethischen fragen in
dieser komplizierten sache und zwar
gesine bei youtube fragt sich ungeimpfte
personen beziehungsweise sie schreibt
einen kommentar ungeimpfte personen
dürfen anderen keine krankenhausbetten
wegnehmen das wäre sowohl konsequent als
auch verhältnismäßig herr augsburg jetzt
sie hatten es ja auch schon angesprochen
ist das vielleicht ja auch gar nicht
immer so klar zu trennen und zu
unterscheiden und vielleicht auch die
frage auch mit dem während wem was weg
also wie will man hier jetzt bei uns in
deutschland dann tatsächlich eine regel
finden die fair und gerecht für alle ist
wenn es darum geht uns alle zu schützen
also was die zuschauer anspricht ist
natürlich das problem dass die
verteilung von knappen ressourcen
krankenhausbetten oder intensivbetten
beatmungs grenzen insbesondere ja etwas
ist das wir von anfang an so als
schreckensszenario im blick gehabt haben
aber gleichzeitig ist auch klar dass man
da in der deutschen rechtsordnung
eindeutig keine differenzierungen
vornehmen dahingehend etwas zu sagen der
oder diejenige ist selbst schuld daran
wenn wir das irgendwie an dieser stelle
zuließen und da irgendwie eine
abweichung von einer banalen
grundlegenden gleichheit der menschen
akzeptierten wohin würde uns das denn
führen was ist denn dann mit dem der
sein leben lang kettenraucher waren
jetzt lungenkarzinom hat wird er auch
nicht behandelt ist ja auch selber
schuld was es mit dem der auf einer
nassen straße zu schnell in die kurve
gefahren und am baum gelandet ist haben
wir da gar nicht draußen im
rettungswagen und wir sagen seit dessen
verantwortung da müssen wir sehr
aufpassen dass wir als gesellschaft
nicht die den nachvollziehbaren ärger
die natürlich insbesondere die geimpften
empfinden so weit ausdehnen dass hier
das zu einer seiner söhne bock irgendwie
konstellation machen und die geimpften
für alles in verantwortung nehmen und
ihnen auch schlimmste sanktionen eben in
diesem falle eine nichtbehandlung bei
einer potenziell tödlichen erkrankungen
in aussicht stellen
eine andere spannende frage jetzt auch
gerade hier zu dem was wir aus
österreich gehört haben aus dem beispiel
österreich lese ich hier von kings tief
bei youtube er fragt sich warum ist auf
der arbeit 3g akzeptiert so ist es ja in
österreich aktuell und im
gesellschaftlichen leben gilt 2 gähn ja
dann müsste man natürlich die
österreichischen oder auch die deutschen
politiker fragen wie das vorhaben im
ergebnis ist es wahrscheinlich genau
deshalb so weil wir ja auch in den
vergangenen monaten gesehen haben dass
im arbeitsleben einiges weiter gelaufen
ist als kultur schule universität und
ähnliches schon deutlich beschränkt war
das heißt da versucht man den
wirtschaftsbetrieb insgesamt am laufen
zu halten da wäre es eben problematisch
wenn wir sagen würden es werden auch
breiter ebene menschen die weder gelesen
noch geimpft sind ausgeschlossen sondern
man versucht da so eine öffnungsklausel
gewissermaßen zu haben und gleichzeitig
ist offensichtlich die idee dass man
dass man an anderen stellen da ein
bisschen die die zügel schärfer anziehen
kann wenn sie herrn thorsten heute
gehört haben hat er ja sofort gesagt
dass er starke zweifel hat ob das
wirklich so sinnvoll ist 3g regelung
zeigen regelungen einzuführen wenn man
sich vor augen führt dass an der stelle
in den bei diesem jahr mal vorübergehend
und kontakten ja immer auch das risiko
mit stinkt das sich eben geimpfte person
selbst anstecken oder was noch
wahrscheinlicher ist andere insbesondere
ungeimpfte anstecken das ist das was ich
eben angesprochen hat dass es auch in
deutschland so es herrscht irgendwie
vorstellungen vor wer sich geimpft hat
ist damit sicher das stimmt unter den
data bedingungen nicht mehr in die
impfung ist ein ganz wichtiger schritt
sie ist ein wichtiges element um sich
selbst und auch andere zu schützen aber
eben nicht mit der intensität wie wir
das mal gedacht und gehofft haben und
jetzt ist natürlich mit diesen neuen
plänen sei es in österreich oder
vielleicht auch das was in deutschland
neu entschieden wird nimmt das ja auch
viele menschen im privatsektor mit in
die pflicht die sollen nämlich dann
kontrollieren also wer es geimpft
getestet nicht geimpft ist das den
zuzumuten ist das denn recht und gesetz
kann man darf man das einfach so machen
und als staat sagen und im privatsektor
soll das da besser kontrolliert werden
das kann man natürlich kräftig geld
schon machen also sie müssen ja auch
endlich jugendschutz vorgaben in
gaststätten kontrollieren und ähnliches
das ist nicht per se ausgeschlossen dass
man das macht aber es ist natürlich dann
auch zu erwarten dass ist zu solchen
webseiten kommen wird wie es der kollege
beschrieben hat aus österreich wie würde
es auch bei uns gehen also keinen
irgendwie österreichisches phänomen
glaube ich und bis zum gewissen punkt
ist das auch in ordnung so weil eine
hundertprozentige durchsetzung also
polizei staatliche strukturen
sondergleichen voraussetzen würde aber
wir müssen eben sehen dass wir im
wesentlichen hier mit einem herrn der
nutzer abschreckungselement agieren ich
glaube auch dass diese beschränkung
maßnahmen die der beschrieben worden die
bei uns angedacht mit in österreich in
radikaler form umgesetzt sind wirklich
zum gutteil auch dazu dienen den
ungeimpften das leben schwer zu machen
und da kommt genau dieses problem zum
tragen dass das dann eine starke
zeitliche verzögerung verlangt also oder
brauchst jetzt würden an der stelle ja
tatsächlich selbst wenn wir mit diesen
maßnahmen jetzt alles rund 17 millionen
oder sowas ungeimpfte erwachsene dazu
brächten sich impfen zu lassen das würde
monate dauern bis das einen vollen
impfschutz entsprechend
stehen lässt dann sind wir in einer
situation wie vielleicht gar nicht mehr
auszuhalten ist also da müssen wir
einfach aufpassen ob sie sich auch
andere maßnahmen gibt neben dieser
forschen einfach nur druck auf um
ungeimpfte personen auszugehen dass
solche maßnahmen natürlich aber auch nur
sinn machen wenn sie denn am ende auch
wirklich kontrolliert werden und das
passiert darüber wird jetzt auch schon
wieder viel diskutiert und es gibt dafür
sorge und wir haben auch einen beitrag
der sich da mal intensiv beschäftigt hat
wie schwierig das auch werden könnte von
johanna sagt meister und laura rosinus
bahnfahren mit maske als
infektionsschutz sollte es bald nicht
mehr ausreichen die andere parteien
wollen eine bundesweite 3g regel
einführen heißt wer nicht geimpft oder
genesen ist braucht einen test auch beim
bus und bahn fahren nur wer das
kontrollieren soll haben spd fdp und
grüne noch nicht festgelegt
gewerkschaften von polizei und eisenbahn
haben schon einmal abgelehnt also eine
durchgehende kontrolle an den pamir für
mich sicherlich auch personell nicht
leistbar man muss es wohl so machen dass
alle die mitfahren in bussen in zügen
eben geimpft genießen oder getestet sind
und wenn sie erwischt werden dann müssen
sie mit der erheblichen bußgeldern
rechnen und das kann nur
stichprobenartig gehen und das ist sache
der bundespolizei nicht sache der
beschäftigten in den eisenbahnen die
polizei ist natürlich keine
gesundheitsbehörde wir als polizei
kommen dann ins boot und haben dann
unsere aufgabe wenn trotz aufforderung
diese regeln nicht eingehalten werden
und dann die reisen denn eben auch die
züge nicht verlassen wollen nach einem
fahrrad ausschluss dann kommt polizei
ins spiel auch die bundesregierung war
bisher der meinung dass eine
durchsetzung zitat praktisch nicht
durchführbar wäre so steht es in einem
papier von verkehrs gesundheits und
innenministerium vom august heute
erklärt regierungssprecher seibert
allerdings die dringlichkeit der lage
habe sich geändert nun braucht es
konkrete vorgaben der ampel parteien für
ihre pläne offen ist nämlich auch noch
die juristische frage ob die
beförderungspflicht wegen der rasant
gestiegenen corona zahlen überhaupt
ausgesetzt werden darf
wenn du gehört da sind natürlich
wirklich noch viele fragen offen und das
scheint alles nicht so einfach jetzt
gibt es daran grundsätzlich viel kritik
von jetzt vielen menschen die sich nicht
impfen lassen möchten heißt das auch
immer wieder das greift auch
grundsätzlich hier alles in ihrer
freiheitsrechte
freiheitsrechte 1 wo würden sie denn
sagen wo liegt denn die grenze zwischen
persönlicher freiheit und allgemeiner
gesundheitsschutz
naja so pauschal kann man das glaube ich
einfach nicht festlegen das ist insofern
auch ein bisschen in dem beitrag aus
österreich etwas kurz dargestellt waren
sozusagen die individuelle freiheit
endet dort wo gewiss die volksgesundheit
beginnen so stimmt dass wir müssen
natürlich schon sehen dass wir eine
ganze reihe von individuellen
entscheidungen akzeptieren die irgendwie
mittelbar auch das system der
gesundheitsversorgung beeinträchtigen
also zum beispiel einfach in finanzielle
mittel binden die dort irgendwie sonst
anders ausgegeben werden können und das
ist auch gut und richtig so dass wir
sagen hier werden bestimmte auch
individuelle irrationalitäten einfach in
kauf genommen aber auf der anderen seite
ist es eben genau so richtig
festzustellen dass sie nicht einfach
sagen kann meine freiheit steht über
allem anderen und ich darf und so weiter
machen was ich möchte sondern sie endet
müssen sie eine klassische formel dann
an der freiheit des anderen und auch die
gesundheit des anderen ist in diesem
sinne ein freiheitsrecht und das heißt
ich habe eh tisch gesprochen das gebot
der nicht schädigung
verfassungsrechtlich gesprochen geht es
darum dass wir diese miteinander
potenziellen konflikt stehenden
freiheitsrechte in einen angemessenen
ausgleich bringen versuchen sie
möglichst schonend miteinander zu
kombinieren und das heißt eben letztlich
werden wir versuchen ziele wie
gesundheitsschutz und individuellen
freiheit ein ander in einklang zu
bringen in dem sinne dass natürlich
nicht eine sich vollständig durchsetzen
kann aber eben wo ich auch und das haben
wir ja in den vergangenen monaten
gesehen massive freiheits
beeinträchtigungen zulässig sein können
wenn dem ganz erhebliche
gesundheitsgefährdung entgegenstehen und
jetzt heißt es ja auch immer wieder von
jetzt kritikerinnen und kritiker dieser
ganzen neuerungen und maßnahmen dass das
oftmals eine impfpflicht durch die
hintertür sei würden sie sagen auf
dieses thema impfpflicht ja oder nein
gibt es ethisch und juristisch gesehen
überhaupt eine gute eine richtige
antwort
mehr eine antwort gibt es auch
sicherlich nicht und das hängt aber
zusammen dass eben der begriff der
impfpflicht so so vage so ausführungs
bedürftig ist das was wir jetzt sehen
was wir in deutschland auch in
österreich da eben beschrieben bekommen
haben das ist natürlich schon eine art
impfpflicht denn wir wird vom staat den
ungeimpften ein bestimmt der druck
auferlegt sie werden also mit
staatlichen mitteln in die richtung
einer impfung gedrängt die impfpflicht
beginnt nicht erst bei bußgeldern oder
erst recht nicht damit dass mich
irgendwie die bundespolizei aus der
wohnung zerrt und zum hausarzt bringt so
das ist natürlich eine gleitende skala
unterschiedlicher sanktionen die daran
geknüpft werden können und insofern ist
das was wir jetzt im momentan erleben
natürlich eine mittelbare oder meint
auch durch die hintertür eingeführte
impfpflicht die frage ist nur ob das
genügt und verfassungsrechtlich wäre es
natürlich irgendwie wünschenswert dass
man das noch klarer thematisiert was
damit auch erreicht werden soll also ob
es tatsächlich keine andere möglichkeit
gibt der wandel ii gehört zu werden als
ausgerechnet mit einer wie auch immer
ausgestalteten auch welche gruppen auch
immer bezogenen impfpflicht
vielen dank für ihre einschätzung heute
abend herzberg mitglied des deutschen
ethikrats und rechtswissenschaftler
danke dass ihr heute abend zu gast waren
und unsere fragen beantwortet haben wer
gerne schön und
am donnerstag soll das ganze dann also
die neuen core ohne regeln dann im
bundestag beschlossen werden außerdem
ist dann auch
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz von bund
und ländern und wir behalten das ganze
natürlich dann für euch im blick und im
auge und bis dahin macht's gut
[Musik]